so this is the first day i'm going to um
um
so you know
wow
army
okay
okay
uh
thank you
okay
i'll put it in my bag
so
um
uh
okay
so now i have three
all
um
okay
um
um
there
oh my gosh
okay
um
this
is
okay
right
yeah
knew
my station
you can never tell me
you know
um
wow
playlist
that's yeah
okay
is
sure
uh
okay
what's up
is
is
um
i know
right
and you're
okay
um
um
um
pretty far out
um
is
is
okay
uh
me
company
okay
hey
first
yes
is
um
yes
okay
yeah yeah
foreign
um
and uh bill let me first of all say your
lips to god's ears because we thought an
hour ago that any moment president trump
was going to come out here
in the breaking room and we're still
here but he only has 45 minutes before
he's supposed to happen in the south
sometime in the next few minutes we hope
when he goes to minnesota he is going to
find a state that may be a little bit
more difficult to get than it looked
like it was even in 2016 he lost
hillary clinton by one and a half points
back then and now the real third
politics average of polls is showing joe
biden with a 10 point lead
most of the recent polls have hit five
and up eight up nine
a recent one by abc news washington
posted by up by 16
so that may be a little bit of an
outlier we don't know
but the president believes that if he
spends enough time in minnesota he will
be able to flip the city
that would make him the first republican
to win it since 1972 and richard nixon
i mean even in his 49th state win in
1984
ronald reagan couldn't do it we can
expect that the president will go after
joe biden in this event tonight
in bemidji again on the law and order
issue
again on outsourcing jobs as the
president has charged
the obama bible administration did to
china and other places
the president will pledge that he is the
one who can bring these back the
president also looking to improve his
margins
in the hispanic communities about 300
000 hispanics in the state
of minnesota earlier today the white
house and fema announced the single
biggest emergency relief grant it has
ever put out there
to the island nation of puerto rico 11.6
billion dollars to rebuild the power
infrastructure
as well as make improvements to
education this on the third anniversary
of hurricane maria
slamming puerto rico with category five
winds literally destroying the island
and certainly destroying the electrical
grid there
uh the politicians in puerto rico very
happy to have this money but some
question is to
about the timing why the president is
doing this now
when we are within 50 days of the
election bill
thank you
remember
okay
medium
yeah minutes
right
um
huh
so
uh
okay
thank you very much everyone
so a lot of work has been going on with
respect to
the vaccines very successful work i
might add
we have three great great companies
doing
somewhat different variations but
they're all looking very good from the
beginning of the china virus all
nations have understood that our top
priority
must be to develop a vaccine as quickly
as possible to end the
pandemic and get life back to normal
the successful vaccine will not only
save
millions of lives it will put an end to
the restrictions and
some of the things that go on and have
to go on
in the meantime today i want to discuss
the historic progress we're making
to deliver a safe and effective vaccine
in record time and there's never been
anything like this ever
in our history there's never been an in
history period world history
since january america's brilliant
doctors and scientists have been working
around the clock
these are the best medical minds in the
world by far and the
vaccines are going through the gold
standard of
clinical trials and very heavy emphasis
placed on safety three vaccines are
already in the final stage joe biden's
anti-vaccine
theories are putting a lot of lives
at risk and they're only doing it for
political reasons it's very foolish
it's part of their war to try and
discredit the vaccine now that they know
that we essentially have it we'll be
announcing it fairly soon
as part of operation warp speed my
administration is manufacturing all of
the most promising vaccines in advance
and actually it'll be fairly
terry and the general is one of our best
and he is
ready to go we'll have manufactured at
least
100 million vaccine doses before the end
of the year
and likely much more than that hundreds
of millions of doses will be available
every month and we
expect to have enough vaccines for every
american by
april and
again i'll say that even at that later
stage a delivery will go
as fast as it comes they can deliver
they're very good
best i think probably the best in the
world the estimates i'm
providing today are based on the
manufacturing that's in process
and that's in process immediately right
now
we've already exceeded our ambitious
goals
under the defense production act
contracts that we've secured we may
even get far above these numbers the
numbers that i'm telling you today i
think will
exceed them very very substantially
and i think that also includes
distribution i think distribution will
go even quicker than most people think
i'm relying on our military everything
i've done with our military has worked
out very well
in a short time we'll have a safe and
effective vaccine and will
defeat the virus interestingly as i was
saying that
go very well just like
what we did with our military with
respect to isis went very well
long ahead of schedule they have been
incredible
in working with me
let's go to puerto rico because puerto
rico's
been hit very very hard by
a lot of different storms and they're
great people it's a great place i know
it well
great place today my administration is
making the largest
emergency relief award in history to
rebuild puerto rico's electrical grid
and
educational system we're awarding 13
billion dollars to permanently repair
and replace thousands of miles of
transmission and distribution lines that
should have been done many years ago
this was beyond even the storms it was
just
age and a lot of the salt the salt from
that
ocean is a killer for electrical
stations and power
generation systems but on top of the
salt you had these massive
storms or hurricanes come in and maria
in particular
was a disaster but for many years
they've been trying to get this done and
they haven't
had the political willpower in
washington to get it done so we're going
to get it done for them
we're also going to be bringing back
very very major
amounts of medical work you know we used
to have pharmaceutic
pharmaceutical manufacturing at levels
that few places had and a lot of it's
left puerto rico and we're going to
bring that back
especially now since our emphasis is
going to be
making our product so we're going to
bring
pharmaceutical manufacturing back to
puerto rico a lot of it
left over the years over a long period
of time it's been leaving
and going to china and other places so
we're bringing all of that back
this was done in previous
administrations i'd like to just point
out
we've done more for puerto rico than
anybody and this is
just an example of it but we've done
more for puerto rico
by far than anybody we'll also be
launching a major effort to repair and
renovate the schools
across the island following hurricane
maria my administration
immediately deployed the full power of
the federal government to bring the
electric grid
back online so they could at least
temporarily
and it certainly wasn't a permanent fix
it was ripped to shreds
but a lot of that was ripped to shreds
long before even the storm came
in for many many years they've been
trying to do it
but we wanted to restore water supplies
and we did make emergency repairs to
critical infrastructure which we took
care of
and saved countless lives which we did
fema's response in puerto rico included
the longest sustained air mission
supplying food and water in american
history
we supplied it for long after the
hurricane was gone the largest disaster
commodity distribution mission in u.s
history and the largest seabridge
operation in federal disaster aid
u.s history my administration's also
pre-positioned vast quantities of relief
supplies for the future disasters but
unfortunately puerto rico's in uh
in the way of a lot of different storms
a lot of hurricanes and the island is
now stocked with nearly eight times as
much drinking water
and 13 times as much food as it had
before i took office so they're ready to
go if something should happen
they got brushed by a storm recently but
they're in a good position so we're
going to bring back
medical distribution and manufacturing
to puerto rico
and at a level far greater than it was
before
and uh it's been emptied out it's been
largely it largely left the island for
many years
at one point it was it was the talk of
the world and
now it's the talk of the world in a
different way we're bringing it back so
we're going to be bringing it back from
various other parts of the world that's
going to puerto rico
and i think that's going to be very
exciting for the people
and we're undertaking the largest
federal investment in
puerto rico's history so you have a lot
of
i have a lot of friends in puerto rico
and i told them about it
asked them about it conceptually what do
you think and they're very excited
i just want to say by contrast biden's
devastated the island of puerto rico he
joe biden
what he's done to puerto rico meaning
the past administration is
is devastating in 1996 biden voted to
eliminate
a critical tax provision that had
allowed puerto rico to become a dominant
player in global pharmaceutical
manufacturing that's what happened
when biden voted to repeal this
provision the pharmaceutical industry
was ripped out of puerto rico
all incentive to stay there was taken
away
and all of the jobs went to china and
other places but mostly to china that's
what happened
this was done with a vote of biden this
was even before
the obama administration this was uh
this was early on but so
so sad that that was done and then obama
came in and it
got worse so for the people of puerto
rico
they were a disaster for you
and i have to say in a very nice way a
very respectful way
i'm the best thing that ever happened to
puerto rico
nobody even close but as a result the
island's economy under
the previously mentioned names
it just absolutely cratered biden's vote
also left the united states at the mercy
of foreign suppliers for essential
medicines putting our national security
and our health at risk we had a
tremendous
industry potentially going to puerto
rico and they just absolutely cut it
short with bad votes and took all the
incentive away and it went to other
places far away lance
so they really in a sense were voting to
destroy
puerto rico and we're bringing puerto
rico back
and we'll have it done fairly quickly
and the 13 billion dollars is uh
that's a tremendous that's a tremendous
amount of money but it's a very
important amount and i think you're
going to see something
terrific and it's very exciting to me
what the most exciting is bringing the
whole pharmaceutical industry back we've
spoken to various companies and they're
willing to go there
they want to have a little bit of help
but they're willing to go to puerto rico
and puerto rico is going to be very
exciting what's going to happen
they were on the verge of doing it and
they took away all the incentives i
don't know how that
was allowed to happen but they allowed
it to happen that was very very bad for
puerto rico and the
people of puerto rico that was done by
democrats
and a republican is bringing it back
so with that we can take a few questions
and uh
we uh are again very advanced on the
vaccine
we think that sometime in the very near
future we'll have it
where i would say i think i can say uh
years ahead of schedule what it would be
if it were
an administration other than this one it
would have been
you would have been years before you
ever had anything about the fda
john please mr president this this huge
aid package to puerto rico
uh why not a year ago why not two years
ago when not three years ago why 46 days
today
because what we're doing is we've been
working on it for a long time to get it
passed very tough to get things past
democrats where they don't want to see
this happen and they probably certainly
didn't want to see it happen at this
point
but it's a big package it's a great
package and i think the most exciting
part of the package isn't
necessarily the billions of dollars it's
going to be what we do with the
pharmaceutical industry we're going to
get them back into puerto rico they like
being there but
they changed the tax situation they
ripped it out so they really
ripped apart the island and we're going
to bring it back john
it may be simply coincidental but it
does coincide with the big push for
puerto rican voters
that the biden harris campaign yeah i
think that that's well they can't do
anything look
the biden harris campaign what they did
they heard
you know i've gone through it and
whether it was president obama or
vice president biden they were a
disaster for puerto rico
a disaster and uh what we're doing and
what we've done but what we're doing is
something that
uh will be fantastic for many years
in the future bringing back the pharma
pharmaceutical industry manufacturing in
puerto rico
is what they've wanted for years and
we're doing that in addition to the
13 billion dollars yes please mr
president i think i heard you write
saying that
you said that there should you expect to
have enough vaccines for
every american by april so as we sit
here in mid-september
and there have been questions about the
timeline can you
walk us through now and the beginning of
april to which every american can have a
vaccination
i think we may exceed those numbers even
scott do you want to discuss that
quickly sure uh as has been said many
times
okay and we have all the people that are
involved in the actual vaccine
distribution here but
we were just going through this as of
the end of the year
we will have over a hundred million
doses manufactured
the people who are not prioritized list
of including high risk including first
responders
will have the ability to take the
vaccine no one's being mandated to be
vaccinated
at the latest in january and as we said
uh yesterday and or i think yesterday
the
there will be hundreds of millions of
doses delivered
for people to take it during the first
quarter
and so that by april every single
american who wants to be vaccinated will
have the
ability to be vaccinated it's not a
forced vaccination of course
dr fauci said today uh basically echoed
dr redfield's comments that
q2 q3 some point the summer of next year
the entire country potentially or at
least as many americans that need to be
vaccinated will be vaccinated is that
the timeline next summer
that's on the average we think we can
beat that number very substantially
if you don't if you don't mind um the
commerce department essentially gave you
a runway today
to strike a deal after the election do
you expect a tick tock deal before the
election or after the election
i think it could go quickly we have uh
great companies talking to us
about it you know about oracle you know
microsoft
has been involved and let's see whether
or not they're continuing to be
involved walmart is truly a great
company they're very much involved they
want to do something
so we have some great options and maybe
we can keep a lot of people happy but
have the security that we need we have
to have the total security from
china we're just no we're not going to
do anything to jeopardize security
at the same time it's it's an amazing
company very very popular
so that we can do a combination of both
i'd be very happy doing that could go
very quickly that could go
very very fast yeah please mr president
go ahead will you
thank you mr president um on kuwait so
the ambassador to
the kuwaiti ambassador to austria this
week told the iaea
that the kuwaiti government is very
concerned over iran's
constant breaching of the jcpoa
in your discussions with the kuwaitis
today have you discussed
where they stand this week as we go into
the u.n
as the united states tries to extend
sanctions on iran well they just left my
office as you know the oval office
and we had a very good meeting with the
emir
and i think we understand each other
very well they're
uh very excited about a lot of things
that are happening in the middle east
they
they are so excited that we signed the
first two countries and i think they'll
end up
fairly quickly being a part of it i have
i would say seven or eight countries
that want to be a part of it without
even working
uh very easily very quickly nobody
thought this would happen
and not only is it happening it's
happening rather easily we discuss that
very briefly because that's
that's an easy one believe it or not
that whole thing is now
a beautiful puzzle that's coming
together very nicely
but we are uh talking to them and others
about various aspects of the middle east
the middle east is straightening out
with all that's happening you know we've
brought a lot of our troops back a lot
of them are coming back in the
very near future uh we're out of syria
other than we kept the oil i kept the
oil
and we have troops guarding the oil
other than that we're out of syria
we took them off the border between
syria and turkey we had a lot of troops
on
the border ultimately we got it down to
50 and i thought they were in great
danger when you have two armies sitting
there looking to fight
and you have 50 people in the middle i
don't care who you are even if
the you're the u.s those 50 people are
in great danger we took them out
but we had a lot of troops on the border
and we took them out i said look they've
been fighting on their border for
200 years a lot longer than that under
different names
and they can continue to do that that's
not for us we're guarding our own
borders we're doing very well on our
southern border as an example
so we're out of syria except we kept the
oil and we'll make a determination we'll
probably be dealing with the kurds on
the oil and
see what it all ends up but we'll be out
and very importantly uh we're down to
very few soldiers in iraq and uh
we're down we'll be down very shortly
over the next couple of weeks to
4 000 less than 4 000 in afghanistan
and then we'll make that final
determination
a little bit later on we're dealing very
well with the taliban
they're very tough they're very smart
they're very sharp but you know it's
been 19 years and even they are tired of
fighting in all fairness and we really
served as a police force because if we
wanted to do what we had to do we would
have fought a lot differently than they
have over the 19 years
they didn't fight it properly they were
they were
police okay they're not police they're
they're
soldiers so there's a difference the
police nobody has more respect for
police than i do but they have to do
their own policing so we're having some
very good
discussions with the taliban as you
probably heard
it's been public and uh but we'll be
down to
very shortly we'll be down to less than
4 000 soldiers
and uh so we'll be out of there
knowing that uh certain
things have to happen certain things
have to be fulfilled
but 19 years is a long time 8 000 miles
away 19 years is a long time
and the middle east the whole middle
east
equation if you look at what's happened
if you've looked at the
stupidity of decisions that were made
including the
deal that was made i mean take a look at
what happened with
iran had that deal stayed i had not
broken that deal you could have never
done the deal that i'm doing now where
all the countries are pouring in
and i had two calls this morning with
countries that want to know
when can we go into the deal they want
to go it's not that we're giving
anything they want security they want
peace and they're really tired of
fighting
it's incredible they're tired of
fighting they've been fighting for so
many years they're tired of fighting
thank you very much
mr president mr president a question on
the vaccine but first
on puerto rico i heard you many times
over the past couple years saying that
puerto rico got
too much money i mean just last year you
said
uh puerto rico is one of the most
corrupt places on earth
congress you said never again you said
congress gave too much money to puerto
rico why now
we're building that up as a great
medical pharmaceutical manufacturing
area where you know we're going to be
taking back a lot of the
business that we let go for years and
we'll bring
we're going to bring it back they were
very good at it they did a fantastic job
but they
destroyed it with their tax policy they
made it impossible for people to stay so
people went to china
mostly into other countries puerto rico
has been very corrupt in terms of its
politicians you see that they're one
after another
it's been unbelievably corrupt and we're
studying that and working on that and we
think we have a good group of people who
are working very well with the
politicians right now
but i think more exciting than the then
the dollars and you have to do something
with respect to their grid their grid is
a disaster their
generators are wiped out and they've
been wiped out for years long before
maria came they've been wiped out for
years
so if we can build puerto rico back into
a
pharmaceutical manufacturing area
we're going to designate it as such i
think it'll be unbelievable for puerto
rico unbelievable for the people of
puerto rico and we can make it very
successful
in a larger question on the vaccine and
on
on other issues regarding the experts in
your government uh last night you
uh you criticized what christopher wray
told congress your fbi director
you obviously said that the cdc director
was flat wrong on a couple of things uh
this week
uh how is it that uh you don't trust
your own experts do you
do you think you know better no i think
i think i have yeah
in many cases i do uh i think we have a
bigger
problem with china than we have with
russia i think china is a far bigger
problem and i said well that's okay if
you want to think about russia but what
about china
uh i think that's appropriate i thought
that the definition of
antifa was an absolutely incorrect
definition so i speak up i like to speak
up
uh i have fantastic people that's why
we're able to make these great trade
deals that's why we're able to do things
like we're doing today that's why
uh the country has done so well the
country's done
numbers like nobody had we not had the
china plague come in
if the if that virus didn't come in the
plague i call it the plague from china
didn't come in
the numbers we had were were not only
record say they were beyond
anything anyone's ever seen in any
country frankly
now we closed it up and now we're
opening it up
and by the way the democrats ought to
open up their states and they're going
to open them up fast john
the faster the better because they're
hurting their people a lot of damage
done with these extended shutdowns
but we saved millions of lives by doing
it the way we did it
and now we're opening it up and you see
the kind of numbers the manufacturing
numbers see the retail numbers
you look at the employment numbers
they're setting records it's an
incredible thing that's happening
had the plague nut come in we would have
been right now at a level that nobody's
ever seen before
nobody's ever seen but even before it
was at
the highest stock market best
unemployment numbers
and employment numbers were up to 160
million people just short of 160 million
people employed
we were never close to a number like
that and now we're doing it again and
next year
we will have a great economic year i
think one of our best
the postal service had planned on
sending 650 million face masks to
americans back in april that never
happened
uh why not and was it because i don't
know i don't run it to be honest that's
run
as you know that's run by a commission
and
they run it uh i think frankly if they
would raise the price of packaging
you'd end up making a lot of money or
breaking even or doing something the
post office has been
a mess for many many generations but for
certainly decades and
it loses a lot of money it's always lost
a lot of money
and one of the reasons it loses a lot of
money now is that it's delivering all
these packages and every time they
deliver a package they lose three
dollars a package or whatever the number
may be
so i would suggest that they raise the
price of packages
and uh you might get something where it
loses very little or
maybe broke even or maybe even made some
money would can you imagine a thing like
that
and whether it's amazon or any of the
other
internet delivery services
if you did that you'd have a whole
different post office so hopefully
they'll be doing that
in the meantime i know so many people in
the postal system and i've known them
over the years they're incredible people
and they're very secure they're going to
be very secure you know the problem they
have with the ballots not the post
office the problem they have with the
ballots is the people sending the
ballots
and the people counting the ballots and
who are they sending them to
where are they being sent are they being
sent to the wrong areas are they not
being sent at all
there'll be tremendous corruption if
they don't do something about it now
one big hope is that we're in front of
numerous federal judges in nevada
we're in front in pennsylvania as you
know we're in front
in michigan we have numerous court cases
out there that are very well advanced
and you'll start seeing decisions just
like we won the case on
opening up pennsylvania that was a great
decision by a judge
that came down two days ago and that was
a very important decision
so uh but we have a lot of very
important decisions coming down on this
on the scam of
unsolicited ballots where they're
sending out tens of millions of ballots
everybody people that didn't expect them
people are getting inundated with
they'll be showered with ballots
everybody in this room knows
it's a scam okay everybody in this room
even john don't say it john because
it's a scam sending ballots sending
ballots
at a level they are never going to be
able to count them let me ask you
officials vote by mail sir people in the
white house
that's different that's cool solicited
when you solicit when you go out it's
called absentee or solicit
when you go out and you request a ballot
you want to say i want to vote because i
can't be in florida or i can't be
someplace
you request so you're sending something
in it's handled professionally they send
it back
it's a whole thing that's much different
than unsolicited
when you get millions of ballots i heard
numbers like 80 million ballots now
just this week they had another one
another one of the
disasters that took place an election
but look at what happened in
new jersey and they had another one in
new jersey very
very bad different than patterson look
at what happened in new york with
carolyn
uh your congressman
murphy maloney
carolyn maloney look at that i mean look
at that race
carolyn maloney had a race it was a
disaster
ballots are missing ballots are fraught
these are small races easy to
look at what happened in virginia look
at what happened at various other parts
of the country even over the last short
period well
and these aren't 80 million or 50
million or 20 million votes these are
small elections
these are congressional elections where
in theory it's easy
so what's going to happen on november
3rd when
somebody's leading and they said well we
haven't counted the ballots
we have millions of ballots to count
it's a disaster
everyone knows it everyone knows it's a
disaster and i don't expect people here
to say although some people will
some people would say it everyone knows
you don't even have to know politics to
know
and this has nothing to do with post
office by the way where are these
ballots going
who's sending them who's signing them
you have in nevada you have a governor
that signs something
where he doesn't even want verification
of the signature
so what does that mean so he doesn't
even want verification of the signature
so
i think it's going to be
a terrible time for this country and
we're counting on federal judges to do a
great constitutional job when they
are they're right now analyzing it many
many federal judges when they
like i think five or six but many
federal judges
i can tell you in pennsylvania big in
nevada very big i believe it's in front
of a judge in michigan we have
a lot of judges have not yet ruled on
this but
if it's ruled in a different manner or
it's ruled
where uh these millions and millions of
unsolicited people that aren't even
asking there's such a difference
you write in you ask they send it to you
you sign it you send it back that's
perfect
that's absentee there's nothing like
going to the voter booth by the way
nothing
where they check you as you go in
there's nothing like that but that's
absentee that's okay
but the scam of sending millions and
millions of bills and you know who knows
this better than i do
the democrats they know it's going to be
a mess
they know it's going they're going to be
millions of missing ballots or
tremendous numbers of missing ballots
you could be talking about large
percentages of these ballots are going
to be missing
there's going to be fraud it's a
disaster
and everybody and it'll be a lot easier
for me not to bring it up
but everybody knows i'm right and you
don't have to know a lot about
elections you don't have to know a lot
about politics
this is going to be the scam of all time
and hopefully the federal
judges all respect it all highly
respected
hopefully they'll be able to see this
clearly and stop it
okay thank you very much everybody so i
want to congratulate
puerto rico and i think you're going to
have a great period of time
i think you're going to see a rebuilding
of puerto rico thank you very much
you